charles trenet qui enregistre à nouveau
disque c'est un événement que nous
voulions vous faire partager puisque
voici cinq ans me semble-t-il que trenet
n'avait pas mis les pieds dans un studio
c'est une exclusivité antenne 2 que nous
devons à nicole cornu landois voici son
reportage
un trio de comiques célèbre jean
lefebvre jacques villeret et michel leeb
pour tenir compagnie à charles trenet
qui enregistre juste pour rire une
chanson destinée au festival du même nom
qui aura lieu en juillet à montréal
un thème cher à l'auteur de ya de la
joie on lui souhaite autant de succès
je me suis mis au piano sur un très
vieux piano que j'ai à aix en provence
un piano qui ne peut jouer que là parce
que quand on a transporté ailleurs il ne
voulait pas jouer il est habitué cette
vieille maison et à l'heureux sur ce
vieux piano j'ai composé juste brillant
aurich un petit peu
juste pour lui une heure ou deux et puis
se dire anglaise ça va mieux
me rire c'est une chose qui est qui
manifestent quand même le ghana de la
détente de tous les maires le rire c'est
une espèce de drogue pure mais vraiment
pur dans le sens de pure qui ne fait pas
de mal au contraire ça fait du bien de
rire personne qui ne rient pas son
malade certainement d'ailleurs les fous
ne rit jamais ou alors ils ont tari
comme sa maladie mais
ça fait du bien de voir un avis la main
radi par quels mots quel jeu
dans un pays
des plus chaleureux juste pour rire
juste deux formules
juste
n'ont ils
pas encore téléphoné à la société des
auteurs mais je crois que le titre et la
joie
ensuite à nous avoir proposé
dans des cas rires
mm
juste vori geste pour dire juste pour
rire ah ah ah
oui